pretty patel miss patel great to have
you on the show again i do hope you're
well um
lots of lots of course to talk about in
terms of the changes uh
to immigration and asylum but i wonder
if we can start though with
with covid19 and the vaccines those
comments that the prime minister made at
conservatives mp
mps last night when he said that the
uk's vaccine success was
was due to capitalism and greed what did
he mean
well look i actually wasn't in the
meeting so i didn't hear those remarks
but i think first of all
prime minister always acknowledges the
strong success that we've had in terms
of the vaccine not just the
rollout which is incredible but also our
ability as a country to
develop the vaccine the role that
pharmaceutical companies and science and
technology has played in that
and actually i think that speaks to a
great strength that we have
as a country and linked to that of
course look at our contributions to
kovacs the international scheme to get
vaccine supplies elsewhere
and demonstrate that we are very very
strong force for good
internationally when it comes to vaccine
science
and pharmaceutical development well i
understand of course that
you weren't in the meeting but it does
appear that the the prime minister
stopped channeling his inner gordon
gecko and backtrack
perhaps because of the fact that as
things stand reports this morning that
the european union is about to
announce the measures that they can put
in place to slow the transit of vaccines
from the continent to the united kingdom
i wonder what you make of that and
whether or not you see that perhaps as a
a success down to capitalism and greed
well i think first of all when it comes
to the european union
discussions are always ongoing in terms
of the vaccine and supplies of the
vaccine
and it's important it's absolutely
imperative that we all work together
in a collective way and a responsible
way because this is about saving lives
this is exactly what the vaccine is
doing
yesterday we marked the annual the year
anniversary
of lockdown but also took great
reflection as a nation
in terms of the lives that have been
lost and also how far we have come
over the last 12 months so i don't think
this is about you know really just
just sort of criticizing vaccine
supplies we've got to work together
support each other
and just ensure as we've got taking
place anyway across government
that dialogue continues discussions are
constantly underway and that's right and
proper
um well let's move straight on to your
brief shall we home secretary and
some fairly significant changes that
you're making today to immigration
policy the detail of which has already
been quite
quite well reported so i wonder if you
might er
just exactly just establish exactly what
what the point of all this is what what
is the end goal of the changes that
you're making to the immigration system
so today i am effectively announcing a
new plan for immigration
and this builds upon the work that we've
already done with regards to immigration
so we've ended free movement
we've developed a point based system but
that's the legal side
of immigration and migration we have a
fundamental problem actually in the
world when it comes to illegal migration
and lives are being lost too frequently
with people
trying to basically travel flee
but also come to the united kingdom in
the hands of people smugglers
so today i am announcing changes um
which will be subject to consultation
and i'll be announcing this in
parliament later on today
there'll be a command paper where we're
looking at a range of options as to how
we can reform
the entire asylum system and importantly
for people that are fleeing persecution
from terrible parts of the world we know
for a fact there are something like 80
million people that are displaced in the
world
we want to create safe and legal routes
for them
in terms of how they can be protected
and also
be received in our asylum system in the
right way
as asylum seekers and be supported in
their resettlement in the united kingdom
tell us then just a little bit more um
home secretary what are these
legitimate routes to claiming asylum
here in the united kingdom as things
stand isn't it the case that
you have to be in the united kingdom to
make an application for asylum
well that's the point we are looking to
create safe and legal routes
to support people that are feeling
persecution currently we have
records number of people even yesterday
we had 150 people
um in the hands of smugglers come over
to the united kingdom
no one denies there is an issue with
people coming across the channel i'm
just wondering what what these new
legitimate routes to claiming asylum
will be
well we're publishing a paper today
where we're discussing and putting out
consultation
how we will develop new safe and legal
routes working as we've done
as we do already as a government with
the likes of unhcr
refugee agencies to support people
who are fleeing but in country so in
country and how we can develop those
rules because this is really important
by developing safe and legal routes we
stop people from being put in the hands
of smugglers
and people traffickers too many people
have died trying to come to the united
kingdom
we've got to break this people smuggling
model we've got to put in safe and legal
rules
and we've actually got to be able to
help genuine asylum seekers
not just flee persecution but be
resettled in the united kingdom
currently our volume system is
overwhelmed
we have a number of areas that we are
announcing today where we're looking at
that
is where is that where is the evidence
though um homeschooling is the evidence
that they change these changes where is
the evidence that these changes will
will convince people not to take these
routes i mean if you're fleeing
genocide if you're fleeing rape gangs if
you're fleeing
war your priority is survival it strikes
me that the first thing that people will
want to do is get away
rather than necessarily pop down to the
british embassy
well actually that's exactly why we will
create safety legal routes working with
the right kind of partners and to be to
be frank now we've done this already if
you look at the syrian
resettlement scheme 25 000 people have
been resettled in the united kingdom
through a safe and legal route and this
is effectively
what we want to create much more of to
help people
currently the people that are coming
over to the united kingdom are prom
predominantly individual men leaving
behind women and children
that are fleeing persecution that
desperately need help and
we need to change our asylum system from
an end-to-end perspective so there are
lots of structures that we need to
change within the system itself
we need to change our approach not just
to case working but the way in which we
can help people
yes get to the united kingdom and be
resettled in the united kingdom
and currently we simply do not have an
effective system that is doing that
because our system is being gained by
people smugglers and facilitators and
this is what we're seeing on a
day-to-day basis
nearly 60 percent of what we have in our
asylum system right now people there
have come to the united kingdom through
illegal routes put in their own
we've made that point we've made that
point home secretary i just want to know
what happens though the biggest problem
appears to be people
on the other side of the channel coming
to the united kingdom and claiming
asylum under the new system that you're
proposing
if people cross the channel illegally
claim asylum and have that asylum claim
fail what happens to them well part of
our plan and our approach will be around
how we remove people and return people
to their countries that they have
traveled from so we have to remember
that there's any arrangements in place
with with the european union
well we will have rearrangements in
place and that is what we're doing right
now in terms of bilateral negotiations
to put arrangements in place
and it's important to remember if you're
fleeing persecution people can claim
asylum in the first safe country
so france germany italy belgium spain
many people are traveling to the united
kingdom from these safe countries
so the principle of fleeing fleeing
persecution under the refugee convention
and seeking asylum is very much about
yes going to a safe country and people
are still shopping through
safe countries and coming to the united
kingdom but but all of this rests on
those those bilateral agreements doesn't
it if germany says no if france says no
if any of those countries
say no then we all in this essence have
a situation which people are you know
indefinitely detained in the united
kingdom
well it's not just about european union
countries and i think it's important
you've already heard me say this it's
quite it's quite a lot about european
countries though isn't it
who are displaced around the world right
now eu countries also have a moral duty
and a responsibility to be part of this
solution
and today i'll be at the g6 talking
about this very issue and making the
case for
reform of asylum and absolutely sticking
to the principle of claiming asylum in
the first safe country because currently
that is not taking place
we all have a moral duty and
responsibility to save lives
and stop people smuggling and this is a
collective endeavor where we must all
step up
are we uh is part of the proposal that
that's been put out to consultation the
idea that places like gibraltar
the isle of man could be used can you
reject that speculation it certainly
was rejected uh rejected by the
authorities in gibraltar
well first of all all the time people
are being trafficked and smuggled
through illegal routes
we as a government have a duty and a
responsibility to consider all options
and that is the purpose of our
conservation so we are we will look at
third country removal
and we will also do that alongside
looking at bilateral agreements so
this will be work that this government
is undertaking right now
and as part of this consultation we will
put all options on the table in terms of
working with their countries and
countries like denmark already exploring
options like this
and we will continue to explore
bilaterally options in terms of
returning and removing people that have
come to the united kingdom illegally
um home secretary i wonder if we can
just touch on on policing at the tail
end of our
our conversation this morning and and of
course the police bill
uh going through the commons at the
moment um that which we saw
in bristol at the weekend what could the
police
have done in bristol at the weekend
under the proposed legislation that they
can't currently do
well first of all in terms of the
changes
and obviously this is subject to
parliamentary procedure in the commons
and committee stages
with the bill itself this is very much
about changes to static
process protests so as we know
the public public order act needs
updating it was put in place in the
1980s
but we're seeing new tactics being used
by static protesters
so we've seen individuals such as and
organizations like
exile glue themselves to buildings
caused a great deal of public disruption
stop ambulances from getting out to
emergency calls
and the powers events like the events
like the one we saw in bristol the
weekend
could could be policed in the way under
the legislation that we currently have
though
absolutely not and this is the point the
police do not have the powers to remove
individuals
that are causing a disruption and also
threat to life we saw
last year and the year before last as
well through the protest it took place
threats to life
i saw it myself with dangerous dangerous
situations with
particular protesters rigging themselves
up to vehicles into fuel tanks
and putting the lives of other people at
risk alongside
stopping a bog stand of public defense
sorry neil so sorry for interrupting
because we're just running up i'm just
wondering the stuff that you're
describing why is that just not just a
bog standard public order offence
because these are new tactics that
protesters are using and they're
dangerous tactics
so these are tactics that we have to
consider as part of the bill
we're working with the police on this as
well and we work with the police
every time there are protests where
there are issues that we can learn from
and
there are currently gaps in the
legislation as i said the legislation
itself is outdated
it's from the 1980s